ist konkreter tot ja hallo mein name ist
luca und heute google ich mich selbst
wir sehen schon ich bin hier auf der
website google deutschland weil meine
damen und herren wir wissen wir leben in
deutschland ein land wo der sommer
gar keinen sommer war wunderschöne
strände wir wir haben eigentlich fast
gar keine strände deutschland ist scheiß
ja ja wir fangen google mal ist
existiert auf youtube seit mehreren
jahren also als youtuber geht man
einfach seinen eigenen namen bzw mit
irgendwelchen werben davor dahinter
adjektive et cetera bei google ein und
schaut was die suche so dabei ausspuckt
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal schlichtweg
con kräfte ein und sehen schon direkt
geschafft ab pizza das ist das erste was
kommt liegt vielleicht daran ist meine
pizza morgen rauskommt hey deswegen seht
ihr jetzt auch schon wäre video
eingeblendet weil ich sage jetzt ein
paar sachen darüber morgen am 17
wenig um 15 uhr in der bonner straße 211
in köln verteile kostenlos pizza wie
pizza wird aber nicht nur dort in der
bonner straße 211 m riese in köln raus
kommen sondern auch in vielen weiteren
rewe und edeka es überall in deutschland
verteilt die pizza wird zwischen drei
euro 49 und drei euro 79 kosten das
kommt darauf an wie der filialleiter das
gerade so bestimmen die pizza ist riesig
schmeckt ultra lecker hey ab morgen
erhältlich auch bei euch zuhause ende
mit der werbung jetzt wir machen wir
weiter hier und zwar kommt ja auch noch
shop alters mai die größte quiz nachname
instagram und test aber ich würde sagen
wir googeln einfach mal kontra fda und
da kommt als erstmal youtube-kanal herz
denn gedacht zudem noch ein
wikipedia-artikel congo after autor
wieder ganz kurz hier werbevideo ein
geländer meine damen und herren man
möchte alles transparent machen der
heutigen zeit bevor newstime ankommen
und einer noch irgendwie ans bein kackt
ich schreibe gerade mit meiner mutter
ein buch über mich also meine mutter
schreibt so ein bisschen an den knoten
aus meiner kindheit und meinen teil ist
er so ein bisschen größer
den letzten jahren also von 15 bis 21
jahre das buch schreiben wir gerade
chance mehr bei instagram oder snap chat
folglich heiße dort laser luca also gern
mal folgen habt ihr schon gesehen dass
weder täglich mehrere stunden zeit rein
investieren um das perfekt hinzubiegen
kommt auch bald irgendwann raus
also ich werde hier als autor
dargestellt konkret ist ein deutscher
video produzent autor und
synchronsprecher der im geist es ist
schon alles gemacht habe schreibt der
veröffentlicht let's play comedy und
loch videoblog videos das heißt quasi
übersetzt videoblog videos ist gut
wikipedia ihr seid definitiv clou können
sie mir so ein paar fakten über mich
aber ich würd sagen wir schauen wir
weiter gehen die suchergebnisse da kommt
erstmal video von mehr die wahrheit über
trocken schon öfter nie wieder kontakt
auch von mir meinen twitter-account bist
du ein kontrast man wie heißt kontraste
mir vornahm kommt diese tester dich quiz
ist natürlich luca seine ukulele heißt
so kohli nie mein logo ist ein smiley
was macht der comedy flotten zocken an
ihnen natürlich beauty und challenger
sie beginnt er seine videos hallo mein
name ist lukas spielt der agraria unter
anderem auch hat er 100 war nur ein
spiel lebte er noch bei seinen eltern
nein er ist umgezogen machte minecraft
tumor
boah
dieses quiz weil ich mache eigentlich
nicht mehr ja machte er zum schluss
warum hast du das gemacht weil er mein
vorbild ist natürlich auswertung und ich
haben
bes
ach so
ich habe nur 40 prozent richtig aber
hier steht zu 40 bin ich sein größter
fan das spiegelt mal wieder meine
intelligenz wieder dann kommt hier
meinen job dann kommt ihr youtube wiki
von crafter meinen instagram und meine
facebook startseite aber jetzt würde ich
sagen gehen wir mal ein verb davor ein
ist kontra tot
kann man ja mal googeln habe ich tot bin
was ist von crafter geboren ist es kein
konkretes
[Musik]
sehen wir uns so ähnlich was ist konkret
dass lieblingsfarbe warum googelt man
sowas wie alt ist konnte luca wie groß
ist von crafter mit wem es contractor
zusammen
minecraft contractor ist tot
ja kann man mal googeln ich würde sagen
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf ist
kontrast atomkraft als tot das sind nur
so war ursachen bist du so doof wie luca
ja also vielmehr findet man jetzt nicht
ich ging noch mal auf ein paar andere
seiten aber das sind alles nur
eigentlich diese ganze bahro sachen weil
ware weil damit dieses minecraft projekt
wo man sich gegenseitig bekämpft hat und
da bin ich immer gestorben ich gehe
jetzt mal bei google ein hat kontra fda
eine freundin kommt ihr alter was die
alles über einen wissen wollen die das
hier googeln hat kontrast geschwister
hat contractors nadja ich heiße der
laser luca könnte mir ja gerne folgen
wann hat konkreter geburtstag war der
kontrast ist ein kanal erstellt ich
würde einfach mal drauf gehen hat
konkret da eine freundin ist sie meine
freundin videos von mir mal wieder hat
konnte eine frau
gute frage
als feste website aller zeiten wo wohnt
luca kong crafter und wo studiert er
beziehungsweise was studiert er luca
wohnt in köln
ist korrekt wir können auch einfach mal
eine gute frage dort
computer eingeben das wäre vielleicht
auch mal ganz ganz lustig zu sehen was
hier so ist welchen musikgeschmack hat
konkret also welchen radiosender rte wie
nennt man sie wie nennt sich die
musikrichtung die themen bzw tags die er
zu der frage ausgewählt hat sind auch
sehr gut und zwar radio youtube musik
youtube radio tomatensaft
yorkshire luca hört gerne future
haushüter basecap idm haus und
elektronik der treibt hier ist eine
spotify players von mir verlinkten man
auch sehr gut das könnte daran liegen
dass sich die playlist gelöscht habe und
eine neue gemacht habe die findet meine
playlist mit der beschreibung verlinkt
also ihr könnt mir gerne bei spotify
folgen
da mache ich regelmäßig nur die da rein
hey dann wisst ihr was nicht so feiern
alles im elektronischen bereich meinte
er mal wenn ich alles im elektronischen
bereich feiern würde dann na ja da gibt
es auch echt komische torres warum ist
konkreter beliebt warum mögen so viele
leute kommen kraft der machte
niveaulosen content ist arrogant und
kein stück lustig du [ __ ] hallo power
ranger xddd kontrast wohl deshalb
beliebt weil ihnen andere leute mögen
und lustig finden du hast eben einen
anderen geschmack ist auch gut so ich
zum beispiel marc duty teil überhaupt
nicht dennoch film in knapp 50
milliarden
ja die weltbevölkerung liegt derzeit bei
knapp acht milliarden menschen und 50
milliarden menschen schauen
juli bei das ist definitiv richtig halte
jeder seinen eigenen geschmack hat und
verschiedene dinge mag und das ist
perfekt sowohl sehr viele leute mögen
weil er lustig und nett ist
geschmackssache weil er lustig ist
vielleicht weil er der beste ist kommt
noch dass beliebt da gibt es eine
erklärung ist einfach nur geil geil will
mich da unterstützt
hier sind jetzt noch sehr sehr viele
andere fragen die zu meiner person
gestellt wurden also wo geschafft da
quasi im titel steht wo leute etwas
wissen wollten um was es irgendwie in
videos geht oder musik oder über meine
person oder warum sind es hier so viele
fragen alltag wieder zurück auf google
aus hass wird liebe konkreter
germanwings play fanfiction
durchsagen wären blick rein dieses bild
allein schon hier meine freien tage sind
jetzt leider vorbei und ich muss wieder
zur schule ich habe einfach keinen bock
luca zu sehen wer kennt nicht das sagt
sich doch jeder visa kerl ist einfach
schuld an allem und was ich auch noch
nicht erzielt habe ist dass seinetwegen
meine beste freundin jetzt tot ist
ist das ja wegen luca diesem möchtegern
youtuber ich habe es immer noch nicht
verkraftet jeden tag fertig mich in mein
zimmer um zu heulen wie konnte er nur er
hat sie immer und immer und immer wieder
gemobbt bis sie nicht mehr konnte und
sich umgebracht habe dies ist der grund
warum ich ihn hasse ich will und kann
ihm nicht verzeihen nicht für das was er
getan hat ach egal ich muss jetzt los
der weg zur schule verlief relativ ruhig
außer diese komischen kinder die meinen
so früh morgens rum schreiben zu müssen
nun ja ich betrete den klassenraum und
sehe wie mich alle ansprachen am
liebsten würde ich sie jetzt anbrüllen
wasg lasst ihr so noch nie so ein
mädchen gesehen was nächtelang durch
geholt hat jetzt tun nicht so als ob es
reicht ich habe keinen bock mehr mir das
von dir gefallen zu lassen halt die
fresse luca du bist doch schuld an ihrem
tod deinetwegen hat sich oben gebaut
weil du sie immer weiter morden musste
was sehen sie hier für eine scheiße vor
ort wir befinden uns wieder auf google
deutschland
dieses land was kann man denn noch so
eingeben
wir hatten bisher ist kontraste hat
konkreter r wird von kraft da gib mir
mal einer kommt gar nix in dem ich meine
wir können das ganze jetzt mal nicht mit
kontraste eingeben sondern mit luca also
ist luca cordalis verheiratet ist lukas
schwul ist luca ein mädchen
würde ich echt bei dessen herkunft und
bedeutung der name ist die italienische
form des namens lukas und des
griechischen lokal in italien und
griechenland ist der name ausschließlich
männlichen ungarn und kroatien ist der
name in der schreibweise mit c
ausschließlich weiblich
also
wenn den ungarn und kroatien den namen
lou gehört dann ist es wahrscheinlich
ein mädchen ausschließlich weiblich und
wird luther eine variante von lucia
ausgesprochene deutschland wurde der
name als die weibliche form von lukas
verstanden und galt früher als weiblich
als kurzform des namens in china die
leuchte nimmt der ebenfalls eine
weibliche position in der name luca wird
in deutschland seit mitte der 90er und
1990 er jahre an neugeborene vergeben
über winkt als vorname für jungen
ich bin ein junger und da ist mein
schrank wenn wir einfach nur mal luca
eingeben kommt als erstes ein paar
artikel dance dance dance with a heavy
und princeton die gewinner dann haben
wir hier lukas schwängert mit dollar den
boden kontraste luca und luca shop wenn
man einfach nur fucking luca bei google
eingibt kommt der luca shop als dritte
website um einen kanal als zweite
alter
sie irrte er war vor ebene familie denkt
sich so ja wir kriegen hier ein zweites
kind das wie nennen wir das dann kommen
wir die bremer nach dem namen luca und
dann sehen erst am main kanal
und denken sich dann wahrscheinlich so
nennen wir unser kind vielleicht doch
nicht
das war es jetzt auch vom video meine
damen und herren sind oben wieder ganz
kurz werbe video eingeblendet weil ich
euch noch mal ganz kurz darauf hinweisen
wollte das morgen wie gesagt könnt ihr
gerne die bonner straße 211 in köln
kommen 15 uhr dort verteidigt kostenlos
pizza und bilder mit mir machen morgen
kommt allgemein meine pizza aus das
heißt die wirklich sehr freuen wenn ihr
vielleicht beim rewe geht und auch wenn
ihr sagt riki drei euro fünfzig für die
pizza ist viel zu viel probiert sie
einfach mal weg wirklich für mich ist es
eine der leckersten pizzen die ich je
gegessen habe zudem launcht am ersten
zwölf neues merchandise unter anderem
dieser auch was heißt rudi hallo mein
name ist und dann so ein paar
sonderzeichen weil nicht jeder heißt
lukas hier eingesteckt wegen auf jeden
fall und steher und vier weitere
produkte im lukasz ob die kamera ist
nicht gerade ich wäre jetzt in den
nächsten wochen immer mehr von den neuen
produkten zeigen aber das ist auf jeden
fall eines der neuen produkte also ein
chilliger oversize winterhude aber sonst
wäre ich an der stelle doch das video
beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal ein leichter und jetzt meine
damen und herren ihr kennt das bereit
wenn ihr meine videos immer bis zum ende
coop das beste kommt immer zum schluss
das auto endlich ist dieses video jetzt
hier vorbei